A maior aspiração da humanidade
é a paz universal,
a união e o amor
entre todos os seres humanos.
É importante, se atendermos às notícias
que preenchem os nossos telejornais.
Nós complicamos tudo.
São cada vez mais os motivos
que nos afastam
do que aqueles que nos unem.
Nós construímos um mundo triste
e que está a ficar feio.
Mas hoje, eu venho falar-vos
de coisas belas.
trouxe-vos uma flor.
E o que sentimos todos nós
quando observamos flores?
Elas atraem-nos pela sua beleza sublime
maravilham-nos com as suas formas,
as suas corese os aromas perfumados.
Elas fazem-nos sentir
sensações de bem-estar,
de harmonia, de beleza e de alegria.
Já repararam que,
mesmo no coração de Lisboa,
na base do Parque Eduardo VII,
quando o bosque de jacaranda
está todo florido
há mais turistas a fotografar os jacarandás
do que a estátua do Marquês de Pombal?
A ilha da Madeira é um sucesso turístico
durante todos os meses do ano.
E seguramente que não é
por causa das suas praias
com areias brancas, porque as não tem.
É por causa das flores
e da beleza da Natureza.
A festa das flores de Campo Maior
é um sucesso tremendo.
Os afetos que sentimos
nas mulheres daquela vila
a produzirem flores de papel
durante seis meses,
atraem àquela vila alentejana
mais de 900 mil visitantes,
no espaço de apenas uma semana.
O mesmo podemos observar
na Festa dos Tabuleiros de Tomar,
nas romarias de Viana do Castelo
em Ponte de Lima e em tantas terras
que celebram com as flores,
por esse país fora.
Temos um passado e uma história
que nos ligam às flores.
Tivemos o Milagre das Rosas
da Rainha Santa Isabel.
E já tivemos, inclusive,
uma Revolução com uma flor como símbolo.
As flores e a natureza atraem-nos,
e têm o poder de criar
e o dom de criar
afetos entre os seres humanos.
O sonho que vos apresento hoje
é muito simples.
Florir Portugal.
Florirmos todos Portugal,
inteiro de norte a sul,
a começar com flores
nas janelas e varandas,
a passar para as estradas e para as praças
das nossas aldeias, vilas e cidades
e seguir pelas beiras das estradas,
campos e paisagens,
Era lindo!
Era passível de criarmos uma onda
em que tornasse possível
nós podermos fazer elevar
a nossa autoestima
e o orgulho nacional.
Criarmos a apetência na produção
e amarmos tudo o que é
português e de Portugal.
Os nossos produtos, as nossas tradições,
os nossos costumes.
Era lindo!
Era lindo mas, para que tal acontecesse,
era preciso que déssemos todos as mãos
e os portugueses não se unem.
Ou será que sim?
Todos nós já nos sentimos unidos
no passado recente, por duas vezes,
A primeira vez foi numa vela por Timor.
É interessante porque, nessa altura,
a Internet ainda não estava desenvolvida,
ainda não havia Facebook.
A segunda foi a propagação
de emoções positivas
pela mão da sociedade civil, em 2004,
com as bandeiras de Portugal à janela.
Foi lindo passarmos das emoções
e chegarmos com os afetos à comoção.
Todos vocês se recordam, seguramente,
do dia da final, em que a seleção
de futebol saiu de Alcochete
e foi até ao estádio da Luz.
Começou com campinos a galope
em cavalos lusitanos,
e levantando a bandeira de Portugal aos ventos.
Foram seguidos por milhares de "motards"
e centenas de milhares de portugueses,
ao longo de todo o percurso.
Mas o melhor estava para vir.
Foi na Ponte Vasco da Gama
onde assistimos a uma quantidade de barcos
a tentar acompanhar freneticamente
o ritmo da seleção.
Esse foi um momento em que todos nós
sentimos um forte aperto no coração,
sentimos os olhos
a banharem-se em lágrimas.
Aquilo que sentimos
foi a mole que nos une,
a cepa e a têmpera de que somos feitos,
a alma portuguesa.
Agora, Portugal todo florido...
A esta hora deve muitos de vocês
devem estar a pensar:
"Este tipo deve estar mas é louco".
Eu também chamei louco
a quem, em 2004, fez o desafio
para colocarmos as bandeiras nas janelas.
Eu não acreditei e confesso
que senti vergonha
quando vi aparecerem as primeiras
bandeiras, timidamente, nas janelas.
Mas, quando vi uma ilha de bandeiras
concentradas numa rua só,
comecei a acreditar.
E quando entrei num táxi
e perguntei ao taxista
o porquê de ter a sua bandeirinha
de Portugal à janela,
fiquei surpreendido porque fui recebido
com uma resposta carregada de afetos,
sobre a nossa bandeira
e sobre o nosso país.
Nesse mesmo dia, quando cheguei a casa,
peguei nos meus dois filhos
e fui comprar uma bandeira
para cada janela da minha casa.
E se, em vez das bandeiras, fossem flores?
Uma onda de flores, a começar,
jamais iria parar.
Conseguiríamos fazer
com que Portugal se tornasse,
através duma onda,
num país maravilhoso,
de ação e contemplação.
Mas será mesmo possível
florirmos Portugal?
Se eu não acreditasse,
seguramente não estava aqui hoje.
Estou aqui porque acredito,
assim como nas vantagens
que vejo que podem advir
para o futuro dos nossos filhos.
Há pouco mais de 60 anos,
não havia uma única árvore em Monsanto,
uma floresta a que hoje chamamos
o "pulmão de Lisboa".
Querer é poder.
Assim, o desafio que vos apresento hoje,
não podia ser mais simples.
Na próxima primavera,
vamos todos pôr flores
nas nossas janelas e varandas.
Vamos lançar essa semente
e cativar quem nos rodeia
para colocar também
flores nas suas janelas.
e vamos todos acreditar
que podemos fazer Portugal
um jardim de verdade,
"à beira-mar plantado".
Sentiríamos então o país a florescer,
em todos os sentidos.
Mas o mais bonito e o mais interessante
e o que mais me toca
é que estaríamos todos
a caminhar na mesma direção
da paz, da felicidade e do amor.
Obrigado.
(Aplausos)